[Music]
in this program work we look at
childhood obesity and we look at this
important challenge for two major
reasons first childhood obesity is not
just a problem for developed countries
like we tend to believe it is actually a
grave challenge for developing countries
as well and this is because children in
developing countries tend to be both
under nutrition and over nutrition what
it means is that they don't have access
to whole-grain great proteins options
vegetables and fresh fruits but at the
same time they have easy access to fast
food and sugary drink and those options
tend to be cheap and available
everywhere the second reason why we want
to study this is because childhood
obesity actually has a long-term
negative consequence for the children
who are obese when they are young they
tend to be obese as adults as well this
affects their long-term health but also
their psychological health their
performance at school and potentially
their social interactions with others
obese children tend to be bullied at
school or have a harder time making
friends and that could affect their
well-being and their relationship
building and because of all these
reasons we want to study childhood
obesity in this project
I worked in advertising before and I'm
now a faculty specialized in marketing
and so I'm very aware that marketing has
been taken the bad name for facilitating
childhood obesity so we see a lot of
fast food or sugary drinks or these
famous brands using marketing to
influence adult and children's behavior
but what we are trying to do in this
project is to take a novel perspective
and to really think about what marketing
is essentially what market is trying to
do is to communicate certain messages
and to influence people's choice so we
could potentially use marketing for the
greater good of the society
we look at children in elementary school
from the first grade to the sixth grade
so usually that means there are six to
12 years old why we chose the school
it's because school is actually the
environment for these children for the
very first time to make their own choice
at home they may not have a choice of
what they want to eat their parents may
decide for them but in school these
children carry cash with them they get
to actually make a decision of what kind
of lunch they want to eat today or what
kind of snack they want to purchase
today without the immediate influence
from their teachers or their parents so
we believe it was that shaping that
behavior is important because it is a
very autonomous empowering decision for
children when they are choosing their
own food or drink for the first time at
school so this is a great place to
educate them what kind of choices they
should be making that may be better for
them
so in this research program what we did
is we team up with UNICEF so we work for
several years together we launched five
different field experiments in various
schools in elementary schools in Panama
and that allow us to enter the school
and try to communicate what is healthy
choice to children there so what we did
in one program is that we basically use
the print ad concept and we use print
ads to permute to communicate what is
drinking clean water so we educate and
promote clean water to children in
Panama what we found is that by telling
it is basically educating them that
drinking clean water is good for their
health potentially just having trainers
in the school background could be quite
effective in increasing their water
consumption and as a result it can help
to reduce the consumption of sugary
product in another program what we try
to do is to use a very typical marketing
tool price promotion to help promote
healthy choices and this is because we
tend to have the perception that
unhealthy products are cheaper so when
we are trying to save money we may go
with fast food or cheap soda and we tend
to perceive healthy products as pricier
while this might be true in some cases
it is not always true so we try to use
price promotion as a way to provide
another incentive or a motivation for
children to pick healthier snacks at
school so we give them limited time
price promotion and healthy snacks and
we track how much children actually
redeem those coupons to get healthy
snacks and as a result purchased fewer
unhealthy snacks and importantly we
found that price promotions can even be
effective for very young children age of
six to eight even for them they
understand what it means to have limited
time to actually use a coupon they
understand the concept of a good deal
and they may end up choosing or
purchasing a healthy snack at school
because this is our discount right now
and hopefully by trying the healthy
option they gradually build a habit and
preference for healthier options in
general
this line of work can inspire and
motivate scientists from all disciplines
to join us because for me I come from
the background of advertising marketing
and so that is my tool for trying to
shape healthy behavior but we believe
that long term change requires more than
marketing we might be able to have price
promotions in a short run but eventually
if we want to make sure how the options
remain affordable and accessible we
actually need more structural changes on
pricing in the marketplace tax and
government regulation so we actually
need scientists from all different areas
to help us accomplish this and actually
improve children's health in the long
run so I hope that this serves and
inspiration to start a dialogue on what
we can do to help tackle this challenge
[Music]